so number three is probably the third
least likely least he seems like a very
fun person but we just don't have a lot
in common he would be a great person to
hang out with but not someone I would
date the second guy seems very put
together cares about his appearance
which is great but I feel like I am not
at that level I think option one he's
more into sports I love you know working
out I think that's really important um
he seems more wholesome doesn't have a
lot of alcohol related searches so yeah
I think I would choose option one this
is going to be crazy he I knew it he
doesn't he doesn't seem very happy I'm
okay with it we'll just chill for a bit
you guys can go off on your own little
mini date and then we can check in
afterwards and see what you guys want to
do after
[Music]
that he wants to focus on himself we
should just end it as as friendship
friendship really nail that in